let's say you despise Western democracy
democracy in all its trappings free
election Town Hall's and list a base
about the proper rules government too
messy too unpredictable too constraining
for your taste and the way these
democracies bands together and lecture
everyone else about individual rights
and freedoms it gets under your skin so
what to do about it you can call out the
hypocrisy and failures of Western
democracies and explain how your ways
better but that's never really worked
for you what did you forget the people
who support is the very foundation of
these democracies to start questioning
the system make the idea occur in their
own minds that democracy and
institutions are failing them their
elite or corrupt puppet masters in the
country they knew is in freefall
to do that you'll need to infiltrate the
information spheres of these democracies
you'll need to turn their most powerful
asset in open mind into their greatest
vulnerability you'll need people to
question the truth now you'll be
familiar of hacking in leaks that
happened in 2016 one was the Democratic
National Committee's networks and the
personal email accounts of its staff
later released on WikiLeaks
after that various online personas like
a supposed Romanian cyber criminal who
didn't speak Romanian aggressively
pushed news of these leaks to
journalists the media took the bait they
were consumed by how much the BNC hated
burning at the time it was that
narrative that far outshines the news
that a group of Russian
sponsored hackers who we called advanced
persistent threat 28 or a PG 28 for
short was carrying out these operations
against the US and there was no shortage
of evidence this group of Russian
government hackers had just appeared out
of nowhere in 2016 we started tracking
this group back in 2014 in the tools
that apt 28 used to compromise its
victims networks demonstrated a
thoughtful well resourced effort that
had taken place for now over a decade
Moscow's time zone from about 9 and 6
p.m.
ap to 20 love to prey on the emails and
contacts of journalists in Chechnya the
Georgian government Eastern European
defence at sashays all targets with an
undeniable interest to the Russian
government we weren't the only ones onto
this government's research teams across
the world were coming to similar
conclusions and observing these same
types of operations but what Russia was
doing in 2016 went far beyond espionage
the dnc hack was just one of many where
stolen data posted online
accompanied by sensational narrative
that amplified in social media for
lightning speed adoption by the media
this didn't ring the alarm bells that a
nation-state was trying to interfere
with the credibility of another internal
affairs so why collectively did we not
see this coming
why did it take months before Americans
understood that they were under a
state-sponsored information attack the
easy answers politics the Obama
administration was caught in a perfect
catch-22 by raising the specter that the
Russian government was interfering in
the u.s. presidential campaign the
administration risked appearing to
meddle in the campaign itself but the
better answer I think is that the US and
the West were utterly unequipped to
recognize and respond to a modern
information
operation despite the fact that the US
had wielded information with devastating
success in an era not so long ago
woman so while the US and the West but
the last 20 years caught up in cyber
security
what networks to harden which
infrastructure did being critical how to
set up armies of cyber warriors and
cyber commands Russia was thinking in
far more consequential terms before the
first iPhone even hit the Shelf the
Russian government understood the risk
and the opportunity the technology
provided in the inner communication and
instant communication that it provided
us and so our realities are increasingly
based on the information that we're
consuming at the palm of our hand and
from the new seeds that were scanning in
the hash tags and stories that we see
trending the Russian government was the
first to recognize how this evolution
had turned your mind into the most
exploitable device on the planet in your
mind is particularly exploitable if
you're accustomed to an unfettered flow
of information now increasingly curated
to your own taste this panorama of
information is so interesting to you
gives a state or anyone for that matter
a perfect backdoor into your mind it's
this new brand of state-sponsored
information operations that can be that
much more successful more insidious and
harder for the target audience that
includes the media to decipher and
characterize if you can get a hashtag
trending on Twitter or Chum the waters
with fake news directed to audiences
primed to receive it or drive
journalists to dissect terabytes of
email for a sense of impropriety all
tactics used in Russian operations then
you've got a shot effectively
camouflaging your operations in the mind
of your target this is what Russia's
long called reflexive control
it's the ability to use information on
someone else so that they make a
decision on their own accord that's
favorable to you
this is nation state great image control
and perception management and it's
conducted by any means many tools
network based or otherwise that will
achieve it take this for another example
in early February 2014 a few weeks
before Russia would invade Crimea a
phone calls posted on YouTube in it
there's two US diplomats they sound like
they're playing kingmaker in Ukraine and
worse they curse the EU for its lack of
feed and leadership in resolving the
crisis the media covers the phone call
and then the ensuing diplomatic backlash
leaves Washington and Europe reeling and
it creates a fissured response and a
feckless attitude towards russia's land
grab in Ukraine you should accomplish
so while hacks phone calls and emails
and networks keep grabbing the headlines
the real operations are the ones that
are influencing the decisions that you
make in the opinions that you hold all
in the service of a nation-state
strategic interest this is power in the
information age and this information is
all that much more seductive all that
much easier to take at face value and
pass on when it's authentic who's not
interested in the truth that's presented
in phone calls and emails that were
never intended for public consumption
but how meaningful is that truth if you
don't know why it's being revealed to
you we must recognize that this place
where we're increasingly living which
we've quaintly termed cyberspace
isn't defined by ones and zeros but by
information and the people behind it
this is far more than a network of
computers and devices this is a network
composed of minds interacting with
computers and devices and for this
network
there's no encryption
there's no firewall no two-factor
authentication no password complex
enough to protect you what you have for
defense far stronger more adaptable it's
always running the latest version it's
the ability to think critically
call out falsehood press for the facts
in above all you must have the courage
to unflinchingly pursue the truth
[Applause]